>> Jon: WELCOME BACK!
MY GUEST TONIGHT, HE RUNS THIS
TOWN, AND IF YOU KNOW WHAT'S
GOOD FOR YA, YOU WILL SHUT UP!
(LAUGHTER)
HE'S THE MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY.
PLES WELCOME BACK TO THE
PROGRAM, MAYOR BILL DeBLASIO!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
♪♪
HOW ARE YA!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US!
>> IT IS A GREAT PLEASURE.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW, THIS IS AN
EXCITING TIME FOR YOU.
YOU'RE ALSO TAKING A MORE
NATIONAL PLATFORM ON THE ISSUE
OF INCOME INEQUALITY.
YOU FEEL THAT'S A REAL INJUSTICE
AND I WANT TO ASK YOU, BEFORE WE
GET INTO THAT, WHAT ALSO ABOUT
HEIGHT INEQUALITY?
(LAUGHTER)
WHAT ABOUT A SITUATION WHERE
THE 1% PERCENTERS TOWER IN THEIR
IVORY LEGS OVER THE  HOY PELOY,
THE PROLATARION, WHO, MAYBE,
ARE CLOSER TO THE RATS, THE
GUTTER, THE SUBWAY?
HOW DO YOU REDISTRIBUTE THAT.
>> I'M KIND OF DARWINIAN ON THIS
ONE.
>> Jon: YEAH!
(LAUGHTER)
>> YOU KNOW, WINNERS, LOSERS.
>> Jon: WHEN HUNDREDS OF US
TIE YOU TO THE GROUND
GULLIVER-STYLE --
>> I'VE HAD THAT
RECURRING NIGHTMARE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: I'VE HAD THE OPPOSITE.
WITH INCOME INEQUALITY,
YOU PUT TOGETHER WHAT'S CALLED A
PROGRESSIVE AGENDA TO ADDRESS
INCOME INEQUALITY.
BASIC TENT POSTS, WHAT CAN BE
DONE?
>> RAISE WAGES AND BENEFITS.
$15 MINIMUM WAGE SHOULD BE
THE MINIMUM IN AMERICA.
>> Jon: I UNDERSTAND THAT FOR
WAL-MART, McDONALD'S.
ARE THERE SMALL BUSINESSES ON
THE MARKET WHO MAY NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT?
IS THAT TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT OR IS
THE IDEA, THAT'S OKAY?
>> YOU CAN ALWAYS HAVE SOME
LOCAL  VARIATIONS, EXCEPTIONS,
BUT MINIMUM-WAGE USED TO MEAN
WHAT YOU COULD ACTUALLY LIVE ON.
NEW YORK CITY, MINIMUM WAGE
$8.75, CAN YOU LIVE IN NEW YORK
CITY ON THAT?
>> Jon: I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
LIVE ANYWHERE ON $8.75.
THESE WAL MARTS AND McDONALD'S
PAY VERY LITTLE AND THE STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PICK UP
THE TAB FOR SERVICES THAT NEED
TO BE RENDERED.
>> FOOD STAMPS, WELFARE, ET
CETERA.
$15 MINIMUM WAGE, BASIC
BENEFITS, PAID SICK DAYS AND
FAMILY LEAVE, THE KIND OF THINGS
WE SEE IN INDUSTRIALIZED NATIONS
ALL OVER THE WORLD, TAX THE
WEALTHY.
HERE'S A CRAZY IDEA, TAX THE
>> Jon: HERE'S ONE WE'LL THROW
TO YOU.
THIS IS CHODDS-APPROVED.
1982, THE S.E.C. DEREGULATED THE
STOCK OPTION BUYBACK FOR
CORPORATE INVESTMENT.
WHAT ABOUT YOU REIN THAT IN, SO
MUCH OF THE PROFITS -- WE HAVE
SOME STATISTICS HERE -- THIS IS
BY THE WAY A HARVARD BUSINESS
REVIEW, THIS IS NO LEFTEST
RAG -- ARE SUGGESTING IF YOU
TAKE BACK THE BUYBACK ON THE
OPEN MARKET IT INADVERTENTLY
INFLATES THE STOCK MARKET, SO
MUCH OF THE WAGE IS PULLED OUT,
NOT BEING REINVESTED INTO THE
COMPANY, GOES TO THE BOARD,
WOULD YOU SUPPORT THAT?
>> YES, IN PROGRESSIVE AGENDA,
AVAILAVLE AT
progressiveagenda.us, BY THE
WAY--
>> Jon: YOU COULDN'T GET .COM?
>> WE TOOK WHATEVER WE COULD.
WE MAKE SURE THE TAX ADVANTAGE
FOR "PERFORMANCE PAY," IS
EXACTLY WHAT YOU WERE REFERRING
TO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THAT.
C.E.O.s MAKE A HUGE AMOUNT OF
MONEY AND THEN IT'S TAX
SHELTERED CURRENTLY, AND WHAT IT
DOES, AS YOU INDICATE, IS MAKES
MATTERS WORSE BECAUSE THE MONEY
DOESN'T GO BACK INTO THE
COMPANY, DOESN'T GO TO WORKERS
OR INVESTMENTS IN THE COMPANY TO
BUILD BETTER JOBS, IT GOES TO
THE FEW.
THE BIGGER PROBLEM IN THE
COUNTRY IS CONCENTRATION OF
WEALTH AND POWER IN THE HANDS OF
THE VERY FEW IS ACTUALLY PULLING
DOWN THE COUNTRY WITH THE
GREATEST INCOME DISPARITY SINCE
BEFORE THE GREAT DEPRESSION.
WITH WE HAVE FOR THE LAST 25
YEARS OR SO THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
FAMILY LITERALLY ADJUSTED FOR
INFLATION HAS GONE BACKWARDS
ECONOMICALLY.
WE HAD A "RECOVERY" SINCE THE
GREAT RECESSION BUT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF GAINS WENT TO THE
TOP 1%.
>> Jon: WITH THESE STATISTICS
SO STARK, WHY IS IT SO DIFFICULT
TO THEN --  IS IT PEOPLE DO NOT
TRUST THAT WHEN THAT MONEY GOES
BACK TO THE GOVERNMENT THAT IT
WILL BE SPENT WISELY, THAT IT
WON'T BE SQUANDERED?
DO THEY ALMOST PREFER IT BEING
SQUANDERED TO THE WEALTHY
C.E.O.s THAN TO THE
GOVERNMENT?
HOW DO YOU REBUILD TRUST IF THAT
IS YOUR PLATFORM THAT THAT MONEY
IS UTILIZED CORRECTLY?
>> I THINK WHEN PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY SEE THEIR GOVERNMENT
ENSURE A DECENT STANDARD OF
LIVING -- AGAIN, $15 MINIMUM
WAGE, PAID SICK LEAVE AND PRE-K,
WHICH WE'RE SO PROUD OF IN THIS
COUNTRY, IT SHOULD BE GIVEN YOU
HAVE FULL-DAY PRE-K FOR THE
KIDS -- WHEN THE FOFT IS
PROVIDING THOSE FUNDAMENTALS,
THERE WILL BE AN INCREASE IN
TRUST.
PEOPLE DIDN'T GET TO VOTE ON A
LOT OF THESE THINGS.
THESE WERE CHANGES IN OUR
PRIVATE SECTOR ECONOMY THAT
HAPPENED WITHOUT DEBATE.
IF I SAID, LET'S TAKE THE WARREN
BUFFET RULE, HE PAYS A LOWER TAX
RATE THAN THE SECRETARY OR
CLERKS WHO WORK IN HIS OFFICE.
WARREN BUFFET SAYS THAT'S WRONG
AND THE AVERAGE AMERICAN SAYS
THAT'S WRONG.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN SAYS WE
SHOULD CLOSE THE HEDGE FUND
LOOPHOLE.
WHY DOES A BILLIONAIRE HEDGE
FUND MANAGER PAY LESS IN TAXES
THAN THE WOMAN WHO CLEANS HIS
BEACH HOUSE OR THE MAN WHO FLIES
HIS PRIVATE JET?
THAT WOULD BE A CONSENSUS
POSITION THAT THOSE IN THAT
POSITION NOT BE ALLOWED -- BUT
WE DIDN'T GET TO VOTE ON THOSE,
JON.
>> Jon: THE OTHER SIDE, PEOPLE
LOOK AT IT AND SAY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND CITY GOVERNMENT
HAS HAD A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY, THEY'VE SPENT ALL THE
MONEY OVER THE PAST 40 YEARS,
YET WE  STILL HAVE INTRACTABLE
POVERTY AND AREAS WE CAN'T FIX
WITH MONEY AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
HOW DO YOU CONVINCE THEM MORE
INTERVENTION, WHAT DO WE DO WITH
THE AREAS THAT SEEM TO BE
IMPERVIOUS TO THOSE KIND OF
INTERVENTIONS?
>> IF YOU ASK IF THERE HAVE
BEEN INSTANCES WHERE GOVERNMENT
WAS BUREAUCRATIC OR WERE
POLITICS INTRUDING IN THE
EQUATION -- OF COURSE. BUT I
THINK WE KNOW THE BASICS DO
WORK.
BASIC EDUCATION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WORKS,
HISTORECALLY, IN THIS COUNTRY,
FROM THE END OF WORLD WAR II
THROUGH THE '70s THERE WAS A
BOOMING MIDDLE CLASS BECAUSE WE
INVESTED.
>> Jon: WE'VE CREATED
NEIGHBORHOODS THROUGH
SEGREGATIONIST POLICIES,
ECONOMIC POLICIES, ET CETERA,
THAT HAVE MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT
FOR INTERVENTIONS TO PERMEATE
THOSE AREAS.
WHAT ABOUT BREAKING THOSE UP SO
THAT PEOPLE DON'T FEEL SO
TRAPPED?
>> ONE OF THE THINGS, I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT, AND ONE OF THE
WAYS IS YOU BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
IN THIS CITY WE HAVE 21,000
UNITS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
HALF A MILLION PEOPLE.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY NEW YORK
CITY WILL CONTINUE TO BE A CITY
FOR EVERY PEOPLE IS IF WE CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IN THE PROCESS, YOU START TO
INTEGRATE COMMUNITIES.
THAT IS ONE OF THE BEGINNINGS OF
A BIGGER CHANGE.
>> Jon: IT WILL BE NICER TO
SEE 200,000 UNITS IN NEW YORK
BECAUSE THAT WILL BRING THE
TOTAL UP TO 200,000.
DONE YOUR BACKGROUND RESEARCH!
00:07:23,109 --> 00:00:00,000
(APPLAUSE)